existe-t-il encore de vrais jeunes
filles ce n'est pas du daphné du maurier
c'est le casse tête de la municipalité
d'enghien les bains
il ya 130 ans le marquis de la course et
léguer par testament une somme destinée
à récompenser dans la commune les jeunes
filles à la meilleure conduite cette
année at on réussi à en trouver une
isabelle staes voici la dernière
rosières d'enghien c'était qu'il ya six
ans reines d'un jour qui a roulé
aujourd'hui employé des postes son père
et surveillants de nuit une jeune fille
vertueuse et de familles modestes comme
le souhaitait le feu marquis alexandre
de la course et qui instaura la
tradition en 1859 la tradition ample
plus tôt c'est plus tellement course que
les gens ne savent plus tellement non
c'est pas mal pour la ville ça fait une
fête quoi ça s'est passé à la main à la
mairie ont couronné avec une gerbe de
roses prennent à des lames est
traditionnellement sur le tombeau du
marais où martine lacout c'est pour vous
remarqué de la coup c'est plus une
couronne sur sa tombe
il n'avait pas prévu l'évolution des
moeurs lorsqu'il les gars une partie de
sa fortune à la commune les intérêts
3000 francs devait récompenser chaque
année la jeune fille la plus vertueuse
il y a trois ans la dernière candidate a
été refusée pour cause de concubinage
mais où sont passés les rosières d'antan
je pense que
la virginité n'est plus tellement à la
mode et que je crois qu'il faudrait
appeler la rosière autrement il faut
l'appeler mise quelque chose
miss il ya deux france et à des mini
sera puis admis ce manque pas de l'appel
n'aurions nous pas mis ce legs par
exemple il reste deux jours pour trouver
la perle rare à enghien même la chienne
de la marquise est à l'affût